ok jetzt merkt man doch schon dass da
einiges an risiko
das ist irgendwie hirten käse oder so ey
leute was geht ab jetzt willkommen bei 1
und ich muss kurz noch mal ein handy auf
lautlos stellen weil sonst macht das
müssen wir störsignale 321 dritten
wollte was geht ab von herzlich
willkommen bei online video ja leute ich
hoffe natürlich geht es gut heute mal
wieder mit einem video auf dass sie mich
eigentlich sehr freue
irgendwie denkt jetzt wahrscheinlich
immer wenn ich nicht sage ich freue mich
auf das video habe ich keinen bock auf
das video aber es gibt natürlich videos
wo ich mich ganz besonders für die zu
drehen die anderen machen natürlich auch
spaß aber heute geht es um was zu essen
ich habe auch recht hunger gut wir haben
noch gar nicht los bin abends aber ich
drehe es einfach jetzt schon und zwar
hab ich ja wahrscheinlich schon am titel
gelesen es geht heute um pizza bestellen
ich habe auf youtube in letzter zeit
sehr auf videos gesehen wo leute pizza
bestellt haben mit ziemlich viel belag
oder so und so was habe ich jetzt nicht
vor wir bestellen heute allerdings auf
pizza und zwar im suchen wir jetzt
gleich mal eine pizzeria das ist immer
ein bisschen schwer also ich bestell dir
einmal bei lieferando und hier in köln
im umkreis gibt es natürlich auch sehr
viele pizzerien die hierhin liefern so
das ding ist du kannst immer was anderes
aussehen wenn du jetzt hier pizza
bestellt kann es noch zutaten nehmen wie
weiß keine ahnung parmesan käse
thunfisch und so weiter und das kannst
du vielleicht weil der anderen nicht und
ich möchte jetzt gerne eine pizza
bestellen wo möglichst viel käse drauf
geklatscht wird weil ich käse eigentlich
echt gerne mag und ich bin mal gespannt
wie die pizza dann aussieht also
eigentlich in diesem amerikanischen stil
so und zwar wollte ich erst mal kurz
nach schon wie viel käse denn eigentlich
auf sondern standard pizza ist irgendwie
30 zentimeter durchmesser
wie viel käse ist an die da war das
gerade käse auf pizza nudeln wir mal wie
viel gramm käse ist auf einer pizza so
circa abkratzen und briefwaage nee also
bei mir waren 2,2 darauf dass 250 gramm
aber das ist nicht unbedingt
repräsentativ gut wie orientiert jetzt
einfach mal an diesen 250 gramm das
heißt wenn ich jetzt eine margarita weil
ich habe halt vor wirklich ne pizza zu
bestellen wo ein kilo käse drauf weiß
ich bin gespannt ob wir es wirklich
machen werden weil das ding ist so ein
kilo ist natürlich schon schwer und das
ding besteht
sich aus käse aber wir schauen einfach
mal ich will eigentlich gar nicht lange
lagern ich hoffe ihr habt jetzt
verstanden worum es geht und ich hier
einfach mal hier auf lieferando
durchsucht jetzt mal ein bisschen bis
ich was vernünftiges gefunden habe und
dann melde ich mich natürlich wieder bei
euch also wie ich das bestellt habe kann
ich euch jetzt leider nicht zeigen
allerdings kann ich einen screenshot
macht und ich habe das jetzt auch mal
nachgestellt und den kann ich euch dann
einfach ständig genannt so wundert euch
nicht
wir können jetzt ihre ausbildung 44
verschiedenen pizzerien okay gut ich das
jetzt eigentlich meine standard pizzeria
also hier mein mitbewohner bestellt auch
so auf bis zu dieser pizzabote ist
eigentlich jeden tag einmal hier kostet
der kleine margarita auch nur 350 wir
nehmen mal die 32 cm groß und jetzt muss
ich mal schauen was ich da drauf kriegen
so leute ich habe jetzt jedoch woanders
bestellt und ich habe jetzt insgesamt
martina 12345 käsesorten konnte ich ja
anklickt also wir haben einmal die
classic margarita in 30 cm und darauf
habe ich mir jetzt einfach mal bestellt
mit käse das kostet 1 euro extra mit
mozzarella nochmal ein euro extra an
sich ist käse ja auch mozzarella und
mozzarella als eine art von käse oder
das habe ich nicht ganz verstanden aber
wenn die beides da angeben bestelle ich
einfach mal beides mit schafskäse auch
nochmal euro dazu mit ihren käse zwei
euro 10
ganz schön teuer und mit parmesan das
ist ja eigentlich nicht auf einer pizza
aber kann man anscheinend auch nehmen
noch mal zwei euro fünfzig dazu wenn ich
die margherita position in den warenkorb
legen sind wie bei 14 eur 50 also recht
viel finde margherita pizza
normalerweise kostet sechs euro 90 plus
1 euro liefer gebühr also 15 euro 50
durch bestellt das jetzt und ich bin mal
gespannt wie lange der kollege braucht
bis er mir dieser käse pizza liefert
vielleicht kommt ja auch eine
benachrichtigung
überleg dir das doch mal das ist ganz
schön viel
wenn wir jetzt mal von den kollegen von
eben ausgehen da gesagt hat auf einer
pizza sind 250 gramm müsste ich ja
insgesamt eigentlich 1250 gramm käse
drauf haben weil ich wohl warte mal
sogar noch mehr
eigentlich sogar 1500 gramm wenn jetzt
halt der käse noch mal extra 250
sind monster 250 g schafskäse 250 bieten
hier so ein paar sachen alles 250 gramm
aber ich gehe mal davon aus das wird
nicht so sein die werden das ja nicht
alles da drauf kriegen also eineinhalb
kilo käse
da bin ich gespannt alte leute ich würde
sagen wir warten einfach mal ein
bisschen ab und ich freue mich wenn es
vielleicht klingelt und mein täglicher
besucher vor der tür steht also wir
sehen uns gleich und ihr könnt ja mal in
die kommentare schreiben was man dann
eventuell noch mal damit bestellen
könnte weiß nicht vielleicht irgendwas
mit nudeln burger oder so schreibe es in
die kommentare
aber ich bin jetzt erstmal auf die pizza
gespannt vielleicht wird es ja auch gar
nichts bis gleicht so leute pizzabote
kommt ja okay ich finde man habe nicht
ich weiß nicht ob ihr das sehen können
habe ich noch viele leute die pizza ist
da irgendwie sie klein aber was man auf
jeden fall sagen muss das ist ziemlich
schwer ich weiß es nicht ich habe gerade
mal überlegt weil ich habe keine waage
hier aber in diesem ice t ist ungefähr
noch die hälfte drin
und hier sind sonst zwei dinger drin das
heißt ein kilogramm wiegt das ding
gefährt und wenn man das jetzt mal
vergleicht ist das ungefähr leicht wer
also ich würde sagen diese pizza wiegt
ungefähr 1 kilogramm klar kommen auch
teig dazu und ja eigentlich nur teig und
der karton aber das ist ja nicht viel
also ich würd sagen so 800 gramm käse
sind sicherlich draufmachen die einfach
jetzt bin ich echt mal gespannt
ich hätte es eigentlich gedacht dass es
noch vertrag aber wir müssen da ist
natürlich mal wieder nicht geschnitten
danke also muss ich das wohl selber
scheint ihnen gefallen ja leute was das
da oben ach so ok wartet schritt auf die
andere kamera und dann geht's weiter
ok ich musste jetzt noch selber
schneiden aber ich glaube der parmesan
der 201 202 euro 50 gekostet hat ist
hier oben drauf und es halt geschmolzen
hätte ich mir auch sparen können also
dafür 52 ist schon sportlich
riechen tut dir auf jeden fall gut
also wir schneiden die mag ich leider
haben wir dort keine gab
deswegen muss ich mitnehmen ok jetzt
merkt man doch schon dass da einiges an
risiko halte die junge juli kommt die
geht es so klein ich runter fallen
guck mal wie viel käse drauf ist
das sieht aus wie käse
das ist irgendwie hier im käse oder so
unter 15 euro 50
jetzt sieht man auf jeden fall dass da
eine menge käse drauf ist moment ich
zeige es euch sofort
ich habe jetzt gerade mal ja also so
sieht das stück aus man kurz wir freuen
uns schlafstellen hier kann man es
eigentlich sehen hier ist der normale
boden wird ein bisschen käse glaube ich
und hier folgten die käse schicht ich
versuche es mal ein bisschen doch das
kann man sowieso ein bisschen trennen
ja also sieht auf jeden fall echt lecker
aus das ding ist ich habe jetzt
überhaupt keinen plan ich bin zwar
eigentlich käse käse freundin ich bin
zwar eigentlich ein echter käse fan aber
ich kenne ich natürlich jetzt auch nicht
damit aus wie genau vierten käse oder
was das jetzt alles war aussieht ich
würde jetzt mal schätzen hier sind vier
verschiedene käsesorten drauf oder
vielleicht firmen keine ahnung aber es
kommt der geschmackstest ihr könnt ja
meine kommentare schreiben wie findet
ihr sie das aussieht lecker aus oder
nicht so okay let's go
[Musik]
also das ist man ordentliche portion
käse also man muss käse wirklich richtig
gerne mögen damit das schmeckt ich
glaube ich könnte auch auf kleinsten die
ganze pizza ist dann werden wir entweder
schlecht oder ich hätte eine überdosis
käse aber es schmeckt eigentlich recht
gut vor allem ist auch noch sehr warm
ja also ich bin eigentlich zufrieden 15
euro ist da viel dafür aber dann willst
du machen also leute zum abschluss noch
mal ein kleiner pizza pommes co
[Musik]
dann würde ich sagen ich hoffe euch hat
das video gefallen lassen auf jeden fall
den daumen nach oben da wenn ich das
nochmal mit irgendwas andere machen sie
keine ahnung wir können es gerne in die
kommentare schreiben
wir sehen uns morgen wieder morgen gibt
es ein cooles video und zwar geht es
morgen auch um bestellungen das wieder
habe ich schon gedreht das kommt morgen
online heißt ja nicht verpasst macht auf
jeden fall die glocke an checkt snapshot
und instagram ab und ja eines morgens
haut rein tut mir leid dass die meisten
von euch jetzt wahrscheinlich wieder
hunger haben
aber so ist das wenn ihm eine videoshow
halten